THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THE LATEST REPORT FEARS ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS CONTINUE TO
DOMINATE GLOBAL MEDIA, NOT A
SURPRISE.
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCES ADDED DEBBIE BURKS WHO
WILL REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
600 PEOPLE ARE VOLUNTARILY
ISOLATING THEMSELVES IN
MASSACHUSETTS AFTER THEY
TRAVELED TO CHINA.
SMART MOVE.
AUSTRALIA WITH ONLY 23 PEOPLE
INFECTED, 15 ALREADY RELEASED
FROM THE HOSPITAL ANNOUNCED AN
EMERGENCY OUTBREAK PLAN THAT
INCLUDES DESIGNATING STADIUMS
FOR MASS QUARANTINES.
MOST PEOPLE HERE THINK IT’S
RIDICULOUS AND NOT NECESSARY
FORCING AT-RISK TOWNS AND
CITIES TO GET VACCINATED IF ONE
SHOULD BE DEVELOPED.
STORES ONLINE, RETAILERS ARE
RUNNING LOW ON N95 MASKS.
EVEN SURGICAL GLOVES.
47 COUNTRIES HAVE REPORTED
DEATHS.
THE DEATH TOLL IS OVER 2800.
ITALY REMAINS THE HARDEST HIT
IN EUROPE WITH 650 PEOPLE
INFECTED.
IN ITALY 17 DEATHS.
SAUDI ARABIA HAS CLOSED ITS TWO
HOLIEST SHRINES TO ALL
FOREIGNERS.
AND THE U.S. STOCK MARKET WE
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TODAY TOOK
OTHER NOSE DAY.
THE LARGEST SINGLE DAY DROP IN
HISTORY FOR THE DOW.
>> CORONAVIRUS FEARS ARE
SENDING STOCKS TUMBLING TODAY.
THE DOW LOSING ALMOST 1200
POINTS.
THE DOW AND S AND P ON TRACK
FOR THE WORST WEEK SINCE THE
2008 FINANCIAL CRISIS.
>> NOT SOMETHING TO BE TAKEN
LIGHTLY.
A LOT OF TRADERS WATCH FOR IT.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT’S NEWLY
-- PENCE SOUGHT TO REASSURE THE
COUNTRY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
BEING PRO-ACTIVE.
>> WE’LL CONTINUE TO BRING THE
FULL RESOURCES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BEAR TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE’RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR
PARTISANSHIP.
THIS PRESIDENT WILL ALWAYS PUT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
AMERICA FIRST.
>> Laura: EVEN BEFORE HE SPOKE,
THE USUAL SUSPECTS CONTINUED TO
LAUNCH THEIR WILDLY UNFAIR AND
DECEITFUL SMEAR CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND TEAM
OF PROFESSIONALS ON HIS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAM.
HEAR ARE THE FIVE BIGGEST LIES.
LIE NUMBER ONE.
VP PENCE ISN’T QUALIFIED TO
MANAGE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE.
>> I EXPRESSED TO HIM THE
CONCERN THAT I HAD OF HIS BEING
IN THIS POSITION WHEN HE WAS
GOVERNOR OF INDIANA SLASHING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BUDGET AND
HAVING SOME CLINICS ESPECIALLY
PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> HE STRUGGLED TO COPE WITH A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS ON H.I.V.
BY DELAYING NEEDLE EXCHANGES.
>> DEEP GOVERNMENT POLICY
RELATED TO HEALTH OR THE SIGNS.
>> LIKE GIVING CHILDREN CRAYONS
TO WRITE IN A COLORING BOOK.
>> Laura: BILL WELD HAS SO MUCH
CREDIBILITY.
THESE ATTACKS ARE SO PATHETIC
THEY’RE NOT WORTH DIG ANY
FILING WITH A RESPONSE.
THEY REALLY HATE THE FACT THAT
MIKE PENCE IS PRO-LIFE.
THAT HE DOESN’T BELIEVE IN
ENABLING DRUG USERS, THAT IS A
NOT A LIBERAL.
BECAUSE ALL THOSE LIBERAL
GOVERNORS ARE DOING SUCH A
GREAT JOB WITH THEIR STATES’
CRISES.
LIE NUMBER TWO.
THE RESPONSE HAMPERED BY TRUMP
BUDGET CUTS.
>> HE TRIED TO CUT BACK ON THE
CDC.
DEFUNDED CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL, CDC SO WE DON’T HAVE
THE ORGANIZATION WE NEED.
>> WE INCREASED THE BUDGET OF
THE CDC, THE PRESIDENT TODAY
HAS WIPED THAT ALL OUT.
>> Laura: SO WRONG THAT EVEN
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS HAD TO
CALL IT OUT REPORTING THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
AND CDC AREN’T SUFFERING FROM
BUDGET CUTS.
FINANCING HAS INCREASED.
HERE IS A LITTLE LESSON FOR MY
LIBERAL FRIENDS.
CONGRESS, NOT THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, HAS THE POWER OF THE
PURSE.
THEY CAN ALWAYS APPROPRIATE
MORE MONEY, GO TO THE PRESIDENT
AND SAY WE NEED MORE MONEY AND
WORK OUT THE BUDGET BETWEEN THE
TWO BRANCHES.
THAT’S HOW IT USUALLY WORKS.
LIE NUMBER THREE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ANTI-SCIENCE.
>> THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS A
WAR ON SCIENCE OFTEN FOR
POLITICAL REASONS AND GUTTED
EXPERTISE.
>> I BELIEVE IN NOT SILENCING
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
>> THEY HAVE NOT TAKEN THE
ADVICE OF SCIENTISTS IN THEIR
OWN ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE ALL KNOW THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN THE COURSE OF HIS
SERVICE HAS DISRESPECTED
SCIENCE AND SCIENTISTS.
>> Laura: NOW GOING BACK TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I LOVE THESE ATTACKS HOW TRUMP
IS ANTI-SCIENCE FROM PEOPLE WHO
WON’T ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN LIFE
BEGINS.
AND WHO SAY THEY ARE LIKE 24
GENDERS.
SPARE US THE LECTURES.
OF COURSE TRUMP MADE IT CLEAR
YESTERDAY HE HAS TRUST IN HIS
PROFESSIONALS INSIDE HIS
WORKING GROUP.
DOES ANYONE THINK IF HE DOESN’T
THINK CHANGES SHOULD BE MADE
ALONG THE WAY HE WON’T MAKE
THEM?
YOU BET HE’LL MAKE THEM.
LIE NUMBER 4.
TRUMP ONLY CARES ABOUT COVID-19
BECAUSE HE CARES ABOUT THE
STOKT MARK.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
THE STOCK MARKET.
>> WHAT HAS JOLTED HIM INTO
ACTION IS WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE STOCK MARKET.
>> THE MOST DANGEROUS THING IS
TRYING TO HAPPY TALK A NATIONAL
HEALTH EMERGENCY BECAUSE YOU
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE STOCK
MARKET.
>> Laura: I WOULD LIKE TO
DIRECT THEIR ATTENTION TO THE
WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCING THE
CREATION OF THE VIRUS TASK
FORCE IN JANUARY AND BIPARTISAN
BRIEFINGS HAVE BEEN HAPPENING
FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS WITH
OFFICIALS FROM THE HHS AND THE
CDC.
I DON’T THINK THAT THE PUBLIC
WANTS A POTENTIAL HEALTH CRISIS
POLITICIZED, DO YOU?
PERHAPS AFTER THIS WEEK’S
REPREHENSIBLE FINGER POINTING
COOLER HEADS MAY PREVAIL?
>> LOOK, THE PRESIDENT SAID TO
ME LOOK, I WANT YOU THE REACH
OUT TO THE REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP BECAUSE WE
WANT TO PUSH POLITICS ASIDE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO
RESPOND TO THIS TO MAKE SURE
THE CDC, ALL OF OUR AGENCIES
HAVE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
>> Laura: OUR POLITICAL LEADERS
NEED TO KNOW THAT WE’RE
PREPARED AND CALM IN DEALING
WITH WHATEVER COMES NEXT.
THE PRESIDENT’S TASK FORCE IS
TAKING THIS THREAT SERIOUSLY
AND THEY UNDERSTAND THE NEED
FOR FULL TRANSPARENCY.
CALM DOWN, WE HAVE NOT HAD
THANK GOODNESS A DEATH YET
BECAUSE OF THIS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE’RE GOING FROM 59 CASES
YESTERDAY.
WE WISH THEY WERE NONE TO 60
TODAY.
THIS IS NOT EXPLODING AT LEAST
NOT YET.
THAT’S A GOOD THING.
FURTHER TRAVEL BANS MAY BE
NECESSARY, MAYBE SOME PUBLIC
EVENTS WILL BE CANCELED AND
SCHOOLS MAY BE CLOSED IN THE
NEAR FUTURE FOR SOME PERIOD OF
TIME.
WE DON’T KNOW YET.
BUT WE’RE AMERICA.
WE’LL DEAL WITH IT AND WE’LL
DEAL WITH IT SMARTLY.
INSTEAD OF GIVING IT PANIC AND
PARTISANSHIP PERHAPS WE SHOULD
THANK THE GOOD LORD WE LIVE IN
THE MOST WELL-EQUIPPED COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD TO WEATHER THESE